ja genau diese Fragen über das
Zusammentreffen von Bund und Ländern
über die entlastungspakete über den
Doppelpunkt zu finanzieren das ist
komplett umgesetzt werden soll und die
ganzen anderen Fragen darüber diskutiert
jetzt die Felix Runde
ja der Kanzler verspricht den
doppelwumms insgesamt 295 Milliarden für
Bürger und Unternehmen als Hilfe in der
Energiekrise eine gaspreisbremse soll
kommen das Wohngeld soll erhöht werden
ein Nachfolger für das 9-euro-ticket auf
den Weg gebracht werden wer was davon
bezahlen soll darum haben eben Bund und
Länder bis eben gerungen wir haben es ja
gehört auch in der Pressekonferenz eine
wirkliche Einigung gab es eben nicht
dennoch steht nicht fest wie die
gaspreisbremse genau funktionieren soll
Deutschland vor dem Winter Krisengipfel
im Kanzleramt das ist unser Thema heute
in der Phönix Runde
Phoenix Runde
schönen guten Abend ich begrüße Sie ganz
herzlich aus Berlin und darf Ihnen meine
Gäste vorstellen bei mir ist Ulrich
Schneider er ist Hauptgeschäftsführer
des Paritätischen Gesamtverbandes und
ich begrüße Michael Hüter Direktor des
Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft IW
mit Sitz in Köln aber heute in Berlin
und zugeschaltet ist uns Carsten
Linnemann er ist der stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der CDU schönen guten Abend
und herzlich willkommen Anna Lehmann
Leiterin der parlamentsredaktion der taz
herr Schneider wir haben es eben ja
gesehen in der Pressekonferenz Olaf
Scholz der Bundeskanzler hat gesagt
sinngemäß die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sollen keine Magenschmerzen mehr
bekommen wenn sie auf ihre Rechnungen
gucken also eine Entlastung versprochen
von insgesamt 200 Milliarden für die
gaspreisbremse 95% 95 Milliarden für die
entlastungspakete glauben sie das dass
die Bürger keine Magenschmerzen mehr
kriegen ich glaube das war wirklich
kommunikativ heute ein Disaster was da
passiert ist
also die Menschen die nicht permanent in
Politikbetrieb drin sind die hatten doch
im Vorfeld jetzt den Eindruck nach eins
ist alles klar die wissen was sie wollen
es gibt eine gaspreisbremse
interessanterweise heißt plötzlich
Bremse nicht mehr Deckel es gibt also
gaspreisdeckel und jetzt geht es nur
darum wer zahlte eigentlich was sonst
kommen die zusammen und die sind ja auch
schon seit Wochen lang am Reden und am
machen am Tun und eigentlich müsste
alles klar sein das macht man ja keine
Pressekonferenz ja und dann stellen sie
fest überhaupt nichts ist klar die
Länder reiben sich verwundert die Augen
und sagen wir wissen überhaupt nicht was
er mit seinen 200 Milliarden jetzt
machen will und solange der wir es nicht
wissen werden wir auch nicht sagen wie
was wir zahlen ansonsten Tiefe
Uneinigkeit und die Menschen in
Deutschland sagen wir die die es nicht
so üblich haben die sind ja schon extrem
nervös und es sie haben auch Angst und
viele sind doch jetzt schon verzweifelt
ohne Gaspreise wenn sie nur vor der
Gemüsetheke stehen
und dann haben wir in Deutschland
Situation aus ganz am rechten Rand hier
AFD und andere rechtsradikale wieder ihr
politisches Süppchen damit kochen wollen
und auch kochen dass sie mit
Montagsdemonstrationen beginnen und hier
wirklich wieder rechtsradikal auf der
Straße gehen die ja nicht einfach nur
entlastungspakete vor und so und die
sagen diese Bundesregierung bringt
nichts unsere demokratischen Institution
bringens nicht und das ist natürlich das
was ich heute hier abgespielt hat Wasser
auf deren Mühlen wenn die Bevölkerung
mit sich da passiert nichts ja man sagt
ja die die es gibt diese gaskommission
die halt eben genau über diese Preis
Bremse hier noch verhandelt die braucht
noch Zeit der Hüter wenn sie es jetzt
beurteilen sie es ähnlich hart wie Herr
Schneider bei 295 Milliarden mal ganz
davon abgesehen wie es verteilt wird
sind ja wirklich eine Menge Geld eine
Menge Geld und es ist auch dann für die
Bürger noch nicht sehr viel gewonnen
wenn sie erfahren wie Sie gaspreisbremse
organisiert wird das wird nämlich sehr
technisch sein und Sie werden es dann
merken wenn über dieses Konstrukt
entweder eine erstatt bei ihnen landet
oder der Gaspreis an anderer ist das ist
technisch außerordentlich kompliziert
und deswegen hat man dafür auch eine
Kommission eingesetzt die Modelle die
wir aus dem Ausland kennen sind auch
nicht alle so einfach zielführend dass
wir die überführen könnten also man muss
in dieser Situation sagen so eine
außerordentlich komplexe Herausforderung
denn wir haben ein Gasmarkt und da fängt
das ganze Übel an wo das Angebot relativ
begrenzt ist wie auch nicht einfach die
Nachfrage reduzieren können der Preis
ist in die Höhe geschossen der Markt ist
nicht liquide und jetzt versucht man in
diesem Markt was man sonst nie tun würde
den Preis zu deckeln weil alle
Folgewirkungen sich dann mindern der
Strompreis die Preise müssen runter weil
das brauchen sowohl die privaten
Haushalt es brauchen aber auch die
Unternehmen die Mittelständler bei denen
sich die Energiepreise vervielfacht
haben es muss dann auch bei der Strom
beim Strompreis sein weil das einfach
durchwirkt und das bei der ganzen
Diskussion ein bisschen fehlt und das
glaube ich der entscheidende Punkt wie
lange glauben wir müssen wir das machen
es wird ein bisschen der Eindruck
erweckt als müssen wir jetzt nur über
diesen Winter und dann wird das im
nächsten Frühjahr alles schon wieder
ganz fröhlich nein wir werden nach
meinem mindestens drei wenn ich vier
Jahre damit zu tun haben wenn man sich
die sogenannten Vorbereitungen
das heißt wir brauchen jetzt eine Lösung
und deswegen ist es so kompliziert die
auch diese vier Jahre tragen muss sie
muss ja funktionieren in der Wirkung und
trotzdem wollen wir dass die Preise
spar-anreize auslösen aber es soll
gleichzeitig kompensiert werden und das
muss jetzt geregelt das heißt aber
deshalb haben Sie Verständnis dafür dass
es nicht Verständnis
machen soll weil einfach dieser
Zwischenstand nur Erwartungen Weg man
hat ja eben auch die Senioren gehört der
eine sagt war noch gar nichts an dieser
war schon ein bisschen was
entscheidend war eigentlich letzte Woche
dass der Bund gesagt hat er geht mit 200
Milliarden Kredit Ermächtigungen in
dieses System rein oder über die Nutzung
des wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds denn
bisher hatte keiner eine Vorstellung wie
diese gaspreisbremse finanziert werden
kann jetzt kann sie finanziert werden
das müssen wir noch fragen wie wird sich
technisch gemacht und das ist eigentlich
die Änderung da kommt aber heute nichts
Neues hinzu das ist schon richtig ja
Herr Linnemann wenn Sie das Hören der
Kanzler hat gesagt 1940 bis 250
Milliarden zahlt der Bund den Rest
müssen die Länder zahlen da kann man ja
als Bürger auch mal denken ja wenn der
Bund schon so viel zahlt dann können die
Länder doch jetzt einfach mal sagen okay
machen wir mit also was ist das ihrer
aus ihrer Sicht von Signal gewesen dass
man das so das ist dann jetzt heute
keine richtige Einigung gab
ich glaube Frau blättner den Bürgern ist
es völlig egal wer es bezahlt
die brauchen Unterstützung nicht alle
aber sehr viele und wir müssen
zielgerichtet vorgehen und wenn jetzt
der Bundeskanzler sagt vor einigen Tagen
da sind 200 Milliarden das stelle ich
jetzt mal ins Schaufenster dann ist das
so eine abstrakte Zahl da kann niemand
was mit anfangen sondern der Bürger will
doch wissen was bleibt konkret bei mir
hängen übrigens auch der gesamte
Mittelstand und da wird dann muss ich ja
ein Professor Hüter zustimmen gerade
eine Erwartungshaltung geschürt die
der wird man nicht nachkommen können
nehmen sie nur mal den den Mittelstand
man ist ja jetzt viel unterwegs man
kriegt ja auch viele Zuschriften wir
haben in Deutschland 3,5 Millionen
Unternehmen jetzt nehme ich nur mal das
verarbeitende Gewerbe die Industrie die
verbraucht sehr viel Gas da gibt es
45.000 Unternehmen und so kleine
Unternehmen sind auch in meinem
Wahlkreis und die sagen sie müssen jetzt
11,5 Millionen Euro mehr zahlen für die
Energiekosten in diesem Jahr jetzt
nehmen wir nur mal durchschnittlich ganz
konservativ gerechnet an jedes
Unternehmen würde eine Million bekommen
also auch die ganz großen jetzt mal im
Durchschnitt wie trimet
Aluminiumhersteller Stahlbereich und so
weiter Nummern Durchschnitt eine Million
dann sitze ich schon bei 45.000
Unternehmen bei 45 Milliarden dann ist
schon ein Viertel von diesen 200
Milliarden Weg das heißt da wird ja eine
Erwartungshaltung hochgezogen die die
der wird man nicht gerecht und ich sage
das wirklich als als Bürger man denkt ja
immer da der wird Parteipolitik gemacht
ich finde Parteipolitik sollte jetzt ein
bisschen ruhen es geht wirklich jetzt
ums ganze es geht um die Frage können
wir unser Geschäftsmodell in Deutschland
das vor allen Dingen auf der Industrie
ruht auch für die Zukunft verteidigen ja
oder nein das klingt ja dann so das
würde das immer noch nicht reichen also
müsste man noch mehr Geld in die Hand
nehmen das ist ja die Frage ob Sie ob
der Bund sich das leisten kann
also wir haben jetzt glaube ich fast den
siebten Monat nach Kriegsbeginn im Juni
hat man sich getroffen und hat gesagt
wir brauchen eine konzertierte Aktion
wir müssen uns erstmal der Lage bewusst
werden dann hat man sich im September
getroffen dann hat man gesagt jetzt
kommen die 200 Milliarden jetzt soll es
eine gaskommission geben jetzt hat man
sich heute getroffen das einzige was für
mich heute bei rumkam ist dass wir auch
im Oktober nicht weiterkommen sondern
erst im November in die Gesetzgebung
gehen müssen wir noch froh sein wenn wir
bis Weihnachten durchkommen weil das ja
auch durch den Bundesrat muss das dauert
mir einfach zu lange das ist der erste
Punkt und der zweite Punkt am Angebot
haben wir bis jetzt nicht nennenswert
etwas geändert wir haben seit sieben
Jahren Krieg Entschuldigung seit sieben
Monaten Krieg und wir haben bei den
Kohlekraftwerken sind wir nicht richtig
vorangekommen bei den Kernkraftwerken
das Angebot wir haben jetzt eine Notlage
es geht jetzt um sehr viel und da darf
man nicht auf irgendwelche
parteipolitischen Programme achten
sondern da muss man Verantwortung
übernehmen okay und das erwarte genau
Verantwortung muss ja auch dann die
Opposition vielleicht übernehmen da
können wir gleich noch mal drüber
sprechen Frau Lehmann wie hier sehen Sie
es als als politische Beobachterin dass
das jetzt halt eben dann doch noch lange
dauert der Kanzler sagt auf der anderen
Seite wir haben wahnsinnig viel und
schnell gemacht wir haben gasfüllstand
von 92%, also wir haben eine Menge auf
den Weg gebracht ja das hat erstmal
geklappt also die Versorgungssicherheit
ist gewährleistet also man kann die
Regierung für vieles kritisieren aber in
einem Punkt muss man sie doch loben also
es fließt kein Gas mehr aus Russland und
es gibt keine Volksaufstände also das
hat geklappt auf der anderen Seite hat
man sich dann doch sehr viel Zeit
gelassen die erst die gaseinlage
einzuführen um sie dann wieder
abzuschaffen und jetzt wird aufs Tempo
gedrückt man hatte ja heute den Abend
den Eindruck da sitzt neben Scholz und
den Ministerpräsidenten natürlich noch
einer mit am Tisch nämlich Christian
Lindner der Bund hat sich erkennbar
dagegen gewehrt den Ländern weitere
finanzversprechen zu machen selbst bei
Sachen die eigentlich eindeutig sind zum
Beispiel 9 Euro Ticket ist doch klar
dass die Länder weitere Mittel brauchen
für den Schienenausbau wieder Keim wenn
man jetzt einen neuen Euro oder 49 Euro
Ticket hat und der Zug kommt nicht weil
die Strecke kaputt ist also das hätte
man machen können hat man aber nicht
gemacht weil im nächsten Jahr muss er
die Schuldenbremse wieder eingehalten
werden und das ist ganz klar
Parteipolitik also es ist klar der Bund
sagt ich halte ihm hier die Mittel
zusammen denn ich möchte am liebsten ja
Christian Lindner mein Haushalt wieder
einhalten wenn das nicht der Fall wäre
dann könnte man sagen man macht Gebrauch
von der Ausnahmeregel Grundgesetz die
ist ja oder auch da in besonderen
Notlagen kann man das machen dann werden
die Verhandlungen heute sicherlich sehr
viel glatter alles übernehmen können
ihrer Meinung dann hätte der Bund
zumindest ein Teil davon übernehmen
können es ist also dass die Länder jetzt
besonders reich sind das merke ich als
Berlinerin nicht also in der Schule
meiner Kinder da ist das Klo immer noch
defekt wahrscheinlich auch
unterschiedlich von Land zu Land der
Frau Lehmann das direkt anspricht ist es
würde das Sinn machen wenn man klar
jetzt sagt es ist eine Notfallsituation
die Schuldenbremse können wir nicht
einhalten also ich habe ja auch so
argumentiert und das veröffentlich
gemacht es ist eine ganz viele Lage die
der Regierung der Kontrolle der
Regierung sich entzieht denn es ist ein
exogener Schock wenn Russland kein Gas
mehr liefert das ist nicht in unseren
Händen darauf zu reagieren jetzt hat man
das faktisch so gemacht dass man das
Geld außerhalb des Bundeshaushalts über
einen vororganisiert das kann man machen
das ist aber auch nichts anderes als das
Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse nur ohne
dass man es deklariert denn was wir ja
brauchen ist wir brauchen ein Vehikel
dass uns über mehrere Jahre die
Finanzmittel jetzt für diese Abfederung
wie eben besprochen am Gasmarkt
bereitstellt und das genau die Leute
wollen wissen was kommt da jetzt raus
aber das ist ja noch nicht gestaltet und
das ist halt die schwierige Frage wann
wird ja auch nicht alles übernehmen
können man wird Fragen können ein
Grundbedarf oder Basisbedarf von 80
Prozent des letztjährigen und dass man
das über mehrere Jahre dann auch
zurückführt und wir müssen Gas einsparen
es ist eine hat nicht mehr diese Rolle
in unserer Energieversorgung wie sie es
im planmäßig in der Energiewende haben
sollte und den muss man sich stellen
also insofern ist die Finanzpolitik
natürlich zentral mir war immer klar
dass das nicht aus dem Haushalt gelegen
kann das hat man die faktisch aus außer
Kraft gesetzt und dem man es in diesem
Seiten in diesem Bypass quasi
organisiert und jetzt muss man aber auch
wie gesagt wirklich diese Mittel auf die
Schiene bringen denn eins ist ganz
wichtig wenn wir über den Winter hin das
nicht schaffen selbst mit dem
Gesetzgebung der spät werden dann wird
auch den Unternehmen die Sicherung ihrer
Wertschöpfung nicht möglich sein und der
Arbeitsplätze und deswegen weil man mein
Vorschlag Last über diesen Winter schon
mal andere Dinge die nicht dauerhaft
etwas kosten beispielsweise die
Vorauszahlung im Steuersystem zu Stunden
oder zu erstatten das kommt am Ende
alles wieder aber es wurde Liquidität
sichern die Unternehmen brauchen
Liquidität damit sie über diesen
Kostenschock der in das enormen Anstiegs
der Gas und Strompreise hinwegkommen und
dieser Pragmatismus fehlt mir ein
bisschen und das hätte auch Brücken
gebaut mit praktischem jetzt greifbarem
nicht vergessen 31 Milliarden sind ja in
den ersten beiden Paketen beschlossen
ist ja nicht das nichts angekommen ist
Heizkostenpauschale
energiepreispauschale Kinderbonus und
andere Dinge sind ja auch gemacht worden
ist schon eine Menge auf dem Weg
gebracht worden also die ersten 30
Milliarden 65 sollen noch folgen gibt es
einen Punkt wo sie sagen ja das ist
richtig das kommt an merken sie das
der Moment kommen ja nur einmal Hilfen
an jetzt gerade überwiesen worden die
300 Euro dann kam an die die 20 Euro
Kinderzuschlag die sind gerade
überwiesen worden und dann haben
Menschen die in Grundsicherung Leben
haben 200 Euro bekommen das ist jetzt
das ist jetzt im Herbst sozusagen
geflossen aber alles andere fließt ja
noch gar nicht im Moment sind sie
erstmal ja Versprechungen fürs nächste
Jahr nächsten Jahr sollen mehr Hartz IV
gezahlt werden der Altersgrundsicherung
im nächsten Jahr soll das und das
Wohngeld erhöht werden das heißt und und
ich weiß nicht die die Menschen sagen
sich ja wie wird es genau aussehen mit
dem Bogen jetzt genauso wie Hüters
hervorhin sagte was sind die Details sie
wollen wissen und auch Herr Lindemann
sagt das ja was habe ich dann im
Portemonnaie was wie wird konkret meine
Entlastung sein und ist auch ganz offen
ja du weißt zu spät und wenn ich höre
dass die Bundesagentur für Arbeit sagt
wir werden so schnell das gar nicht
umsetzen können und hier 50 Euro mehr
auszahlen dann ist es dann noch mal ein
Schlag ein bisschen einmal der Politik
aber vor allen Dingen auch der Menschen
die die da von leben müssen und was ich
nicht ganz verstehe sage ich ganz offen
dass das Wohngeld reformiert werden soll
ist ja nun wirklich nicht neu das wissen
wir seit Anfang des Jahres das dauert
eine Erhöhung von Hartz IV wie jedes
Jahr ins Haus steht zum ersten Januar
ist auch nicht nur wir haben das
Arbeitsministerium April letzten Jahres
darauf hingewiesen dass aufgrund der
Inflationsrate wieder Neuregelung
brauchen haben wir zur Antwort bekommen
wir haben noch nicht die nötigen
statistischen Daten was einschätzen zu
können mit anderen Worten ihr wird
wirklich so überflüssig auf Zeit
gespielt warum packt man die
wohngeldreform jetzt nicht mal an warum
schnürt man sich dieses Paket auf und
sagt okay wir haben jetzt eben in dem
neuen im dritten Entlastungspaket 19
Milliarden Mehrbelastung für die Länder
das ist doch die erstmal anschauen dann
gucken was wir damit machen und dann
kann man immer noch über gaspreisdeckel
und ähnliches reden das versteht nicht
mal Bilder unbedingt diesen doppelwumms
hinlegen mit unheimlich großen Zahlen ja
und dann stolpert man sich auf den Weg
weil man mit so großen Zahlen agieren
muss ich also das ist das Verstehen
man auch das ist so spät kommt ich würde
noch mal gerne darauf schauen wer
eigentlich die Entlastung wirklich
braucht also im Moment ist es ja so die
300 Euro die bekommt jeder Helene Mann
was würden Sie sagen wer also wer
braucht das Geld und wie müsste man es
wirklich verteilen
300 Euro für alle waren ganz großer
Fehler weil der Staat so den Eindruck
erweckt er könnte mit Geld diese Krise
lösen das wird er nicht schaffen weil
wir auf der anderen Seite ja auch das
Thema Inflation haben wir können uns
nicht bis unermessliche Verschulden da
wird es immer einen gewissen Druck geben
ich würde wirklich zielgerichtet
Vorgehen wir haben in der corona-krise
ein ganz großen Fehler gemacht Frau
blättner auch meine Partei meine
Regierung wir waren damals dran wir
haben nicht die Finanzämter genutzt die
Finanzämter genutzt die sehr diskret
Arbeiten die die Zahlen haben die genau
wissen wer braucht Unterstützung und die
würde ich viel stärker nutzen und ich
würde mal mit steuerlichen Sachen
anfangen dass ich den Verlust Vortrag
einige Jahre
zurückrechnen darf dass ich Steuern
Stunden kann Gewerbesteuern ich würde
bei der KfW da fehlen meines Erachtens
energiesicherungskredite wegen mir bis
zu 100%
Staatsgarantie und vieles mehr also ich
würde wirklich zielgerichtet vorgehen
und da könnte man jetzt vieles machen
übrigens auch ohne Bundesrat das hätten
wir in einer Woche erledigt
komischerweise in der Griechenland-Krise
damals und bei den Euro
Rettungsprogrammen da hat das alles
immer irgendwie zwei drei Tage gedauert
und jetzt dauert es Wochen Jahr Monate
und das ist nicht gut und das wäre eine
Aufgabe die man ja auch gemeinsam mit
Regierung und Opposition machen kann
wäre das nicht jetzt ein Punkt wo man
sagen könnte wo sie als als Opposition
auch viel stärker sagen können lass uns
das zusammen machen
grundsätzlich ja ich glaube die Menschen
wollen jetzt alles aber keinen
parteipolitischen Zwang nur wir haben
natürlich eine konstitutive Rolle in
einer Demokratie das heißt mit anderen
Worten wenn wir natürlich fordern das
Angebot eine Energie muss ausgeweitet
werden jetzt seit Wochen seit Monaten
und die Regierung jetzt auch langsam
handelt haben wir ja auch eine wichtige
Rolle in dieser Demokratie und haben das
zumindest ein Teilziel erreicht das
zumindest jetzt zwei Kernkraftwerke ein
paar Monate länger dauern die gasumlage
haben wir auch am Anfang gesagt es wird
so nicht funktionieren also insofern
brauchen wir beides auf der einen Seite
konstruktive Oppositionen auf der
anderen Seite klares zusammenarbeiten da
wo es geht ja wobei das ja heute mit
Bund und Ländern die ja und die Länder
die aus verschiedenen Parteien ja die
Ministerpräsidenten kommen ja auch nicht
funktioniert
das finde ich ja lustig dass sie jetzt
sagen wir müssen das Angebot an Energie
ausweiten wann sie nicht derjenige der
in Nordrhein-Westfalen jahrelang dafür
plädiert hat dass die Mindestabstände
für Windkrafträder größer sein müssten
dass man Anwohnerin schützen müsse also
ich finde die die Botschaft der CDU in
dieser Situation sich jahrelang gegen
den Ausbau der Erneuerbaren zustimmen
und jetzt dann in Atom also die
Kanzlerin hat ja den Atom den den Ausweg
aus der Kernkraft mitgetragen mit
beschlossen und dann zu sagen aber jetzt
braucht man die Kernkraftwerke das ist
unsere letzte Reserve das finde ich
ehrlich gesagt widersprüchlich Situation
so wir haben doch kurzfristig gar nicht
die Möglichkeit schauen Sie wie schnell
geht es denn neue Windkrafträder die
kein Ersatz sind für bestehende sondern
weil die leistungsfähige sind wirklich
neue zu bauen das sind einfach
langwierige Verfahren wir haben aber
drei Atomkraftwerke wenn sie drei
Atomkraftwerke abschalten brauchen die
6000 Windräder der gleiche Strom muss
dann für 6000 Meter und ist nicht in der
gleichen Stabilität da mir geht es ja
nicht darum die Atomkraftwerke und die
den Ausstieg in Frage zu stellen nur wir
haben eine Situation und das meint ja
Lindemann auch wenn wir den Strom des
Stromangebot durch günstigen Strom nicht
ausweiten der Situation wo erfolgreich
weil runtergefahren schlechte schlechte
Wartung die Hälfte Atomkraftwerke nicht
in Betrieb ist wir hatten Wasserständen
Probleme haben wird jetzt nicht alles
tun damit wir sozusagen das bei uns
wenigstens Mobilisierung immer diese
zwei Jahre zu kommen das verstehe ich
und das ist doch keine Debatte gegen
irgendetwas sondern natürlich muss der
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren beschleunigt
werden da bin ich ja völlig bei Ihnen
nur das hilft uns kurzfristig nicht
kurzfristig kriegen wir den Druck auf
den Strompreis für die Menschen drückt
dann wenn wir die günstigeren Produktion
von Strom ermöglichen also dann sind die
drei Atomkraftwerke ehrlich gesagt auch
die drei die letztes Jahr abgeschaltet
dass wir in sechs Atomkraftwerke die
würden uns in dieser Situation helfen
mir geht es nicht darum dass wir das in
Frage stellen wir müssen mit der
Situation umgehen
skeptisch wäre beim Atomkraftwerken
jetzt aber ich glaube schon dass es
jetzt wichtig ist oder ich man muss
jeden zugestehen nein ich gehe noch
einen Schritt weiter ich rechne es jeden
Politikerin sogar hoch an wenn Sie
vielleicht mit alten Einsichten jetzt
schluss macht weil wir in einer völlig
neuen Situation sind die wir so nicht
hatten ganz im Gegenteil ich würde mir
wünschen dass oder auch endlich mit
seinen Glaubensbekenntnissen zur
Schuldenbremse und ähnlichem Schluss
macht weil wir haben eine Zeit wenn du
es müssen sich im Moment tatsächlich
alle bewegen wenn das gemeistert werden
sollte deswegen würde ich nie ein
vorwerfen zusammen vor zwei Jahren hast
ja dies so Jens gedacht ich persönlich
habe zum Beispiel vor zwei Jahren
friedenspolitisch auch ganz anders
gedacht als im Moment tue ich glaube
viel mussten ihre Meinungen ändern aber
nochmal auf die Frage kommt dass da an
was sie gefragt haben wo es hin soll
darf ich noch ganz ich glaube man streut
den Leuten so ein bisschen Sand in die
Augen mit dieser Debatte erstens unsere
Atomkraftwerke sind nicht super
sicherheitsüberprüft sondern die letzte
umfassende Sicherheitsüberprüfung wurde
ausgesetzt sie sind seit 13 Jahren nicht
gründlich sicherheitsüberprüft wenn die
wenn die jetzt länger laufen sollen also
länger als diese drei Monaten da müssten
neue Brennstäbe beschafft werden da
müssen die Sicherheitsstandards die
neuen jetzt erfüllt werden also das
Märchen das ist billige Energie das
stimmt so nicht selbst die Betreiber
wollen diese Investitionen nicht tätigen
das muss der Tag das muss der Staat
machen und den Leuten zu sagen das ist
die billige Energie wir müssen die
einfach bloß was weiß ich drei Monate
drei Jahre länger laufen lassen das
stimmt doch sogar wir wussten der Krieg
hat begonnen am 24 februar und wir
wussten im März das heißt es ist jetzt
ein dreiviertel Jahr vergangen wo nicht
gearbeitet wurde an diesen Themen wir
haben gerade zwei Kohlekraftwerke wieder
in Betrieb genommen viel mehr wer
möglich gewesen und wir haben nicht weit
von vorne rein von der von den Grünen
Bundesministern verhindern vor Lemke wie
auch Herr habe verhindert wurde die
Prüfung dieser Frage dann natürlich
müssen wir das dann machen aber dann hat
das ein zeitvorlauf aber wir wussten
doch dass die Welt eine andere war ab
dem 24
aber bin nicht richtig informiert werden
wir die Kernkraftwerke und das hat meine
Skepsis aus das bleibt hochgefährliche
Technologie wenn wir diese
Kernkraftwerke wieder im Betrieb nehmen
hätten wir glaube ich eine Absenkung des
Gaspreises um 4 Cent pro Kilowattstunden
und jetzt die Frage ist es das Risiko
wert für Cent heißt im Klartext 10
Milliarden das so einfach nicht zu
rechnen nehmen Sie das eine Kraftwerk
was in Niedersachsen nicht genommen wird
in dem Augenblick muss abgestellt wird
müssen sie daneben ein Gaskraftwerk in
Dauerbetrieb hochfahren unser Problem
ist dass wir im Augenblick aufgrund der
Gesamtlage der unzureichenden
Angebotsmenge die Gaskraftwerke nicht
als Spitzenlast haben das war ja
eigentlich die Idee der Energie weil die
werden wir mal zugeschaltet wieder
abgeschaltet sind dauerhaft den
Betrieben und deswegen haben wir auch
diesen dauerhaften Transfer des
Gaspreises in den Strompreis und das
würde sich über den Winter fortsetzen
alles was wir tun und selbst wenn wir
jetzt endspeichern was wir dann auch
planmäßig gelingen muss jetzt in den
nächsten Monaten würde den markenstück
beruhigen aber klar ist alles was hier
verbilligt hilft uns es hilft uns über
diese Zeit hinwegzukommen und die ist
halt nicht Ostern vorbei das ist der
entscheidende Punkt
langfristig an den sie sagen aber man
muss jetzt ganz schnell den Leuten
helfen also nochmal diese Frage was
befürchten sie für den Winter was
befürchten sie auch an sozialen Unruhen
wenn das jetzt nicht schnell
funktioniert ich glaube die
Bundesregierung hätte es ja in der Hand
die Menschen zu beruhigen mit
tatkräftigen schnellen Handel und da bin
ich ein Stichwort aufgreifen dass er
Linnemann ja vorhin auf dem Bereich der
Wirtschaft bemüht hat den muss man auch
auf die Bereich der Haushalte an wenn
die Zielgenauigkeit wir haben
wirklich unheimlich viel Geld finde ich
Entlastungspaket bisher aus dem Fenster
geworfen der Tankrabatt war wirklich
so eine Sache die hat doch keiner mehr
verstanden wieso die staatliche
Unterstützung vom Hubraum abhängt den
jemand hat und dann für drei Monate für
unsere Urlaubsfahrten danach ist wieder
Schluss was soll das das ich die einzige
Erklärung die ich hatte warten
genauso skeptisch gesehen weil es auch
Gießkanne ist hat mich aber dann einfach
aus persönlichem Erleben auch eines
Besseren belehren lassen ich habe Leute
erlebt ich fahre täglich Regionalbahn
ich habe Leute erlebt die haben zum
ersten Mal überhaupt mal Ausflug machen
konnten und ich habe gesagt so wunderbar
das ist immer zu sehen können mit ihren
Kindern oder in die Berge das heißt wir
haben gelernt wir sind ein Volk
offensichtlich was unheimlich gerne Bahn
fährt selbst haben wir die Toilette
nicht aufgehen selbst dann wenn die zu
spät kommt die Leute und deswegen fand
ich selber aber anderen Dinge andere
Dinge würde ich sagen wir müssen mehr
Zielgenauigkeit rein kriegen wir haben
40 Prozent der Bevölkerung die überhaupt
nichts Erspartes haben wenn die eine
hohe Nachzahlung leisten müssen dann
sind die am Ende wir haben jetzt schon
in unserem Beratungsstellen Familien die
wollen Kredite aufnehmen um um
Nachzahlung leisten zu können also da
würden ja eine Spirale rein in der
Verschuldung kommen die nicht mehr raus
und und und deswegen sagen wir wir
sollten es wäre besser gewesen statt mit
der Gießkanne zu operieren und jeden und
alle beglücken zu wollen wirklich sich
zu konzentrieren auf diese untersten 40
Prozent und auch beim gaspreisdeckel
sind wir deshalb immer skeptisch gewesen
jetzt soll er kommen okay muss man das
Beste daraus machen aber gaspreisdeckel
bedient natürlich auch Haushalte ja die
erstmal klarkommen auch die nächsten
zwei Jahre klarkommen egal wie der
Gaspreis aussieht und deswegen sagen wir
zielgerichtet wäre besser gewesen
Direktzahlung auch die 300 Euro nochmal
als Beispiel das knapp genug Modelle die
Sachen warum zahlen die 300 Euro aus und
machen dann ab bestimmten mittleren
Einkommen von 4000 pro Kopf
Bruttoeinkommen ein Steuersatz von 100%
drauf dann gibt es nichts Punkt und
sowas hätte ich sehr Elefant
zielgerichtet zu agieren ja Helen wie
kann man zielgerichtet für Unternehmen
und für die Wirtschaft agieren wenn man
jetzt hört bei den Haushalten hätte man
das anders anlegen müssen oder müsste
man es anders anlegen wie kann das für
ja für für die Wirtschaft gelten weil da
gibt es natürlich auch große
Unterschiede zwischen denen die es
wirklich nötig haben und denen die es
nicht nötig haben
absolut ich würde sie bei Corona machen
ich würde bestimmte Parameter setzen
natürlich ist es entscheidend welchen
Energieanteil ich habe am Produkt an den
Gesamtkosten die Energiekosten und
einiges mehr und ich würde mir wünschen
wenn diese Kommission über die jeden Tag
alle reden muss dann unglaublicher Druck
jetzt auf die Lasten die hätten
eigentlich
wochenlang in Ruhe Tagen können jetzt
kriegen wir diesen Druck die müssen
diese Parameter vorgeben aber Frau
Plettner da ich zugeschaltet bin konnte
ich eben nicht nicht eingreifen vor
Lehmann hat ja in einem Punkt Recht und
den möchte ich mal eben anbringen das
Thema Thema Windkraft beim Thema
Windkraft scheidet es ja nicht am
Abstand sondern wenn wir die
Gerichtsverfahren sehen an Artenschutz
die Genehmigungsverfahren dauern viel zu
lange wir bekommen den Strom von der von
der Nordsee nicht in den Süden weil die
Leitung nicht gelegt werden eigentlich
brauchen wir 12.000 km wir haben im
letzten Jahr nur 96 km geschafft das
eine Strecke von Bonn nach Bochum
und wir sehen jetzt wenn ich diesen
Punkt anbringen darf dass wir eigentlich
seit Jahren immer in krisenmodus
unterwegs sind und diese ganzen Probleme
mit denen wir es heute zu tun haben
diese Genehmigungsverfahren das sehen
wir doch überall wenn man Jungs Startup
hat bis der etwas genehmigt bekommt bis
hin zu Bahntrassen etc wir sehen das bei
der Bürokratie bei der Reglementierung
wir sind eigentlich immer nur im
krisenmodus unterwegs und sagen diese
ganzen Dinge lösen wir wenn die Krise
vorbei ist und wenn die Krise vorbei ist
schon die neue Krise da und dann fällt
uns das alles auf die Füße und damit
muss jetzt endlich Schluss sein die
Krise darf nicht mehr als Ausrede gelten
etwas nicht zu tun das ist der Grund
warum wir in Deutschland so dicke
Bretter haben die mittlerweile gar nicht
mehr durch Bord werden sondern nur noch
bemalt werden wir wissen ja das stimmt
nicht einfach traurig wir wissen aber
schon mehr im Kanzleramt saß die letzten
16 Jahre das war nämlich ihre Partei
ja Frau blättner da haben wir auch eine
Verantwortung zu tragen das macht es nur
nicht besser ich bin mit einem ganz
anderen Anspruch in die Politik gegangen
gebe ich zu vielleicht war ich ein
bisschen naiv aber ich wollte die Welt
verändern ich wollte Bretter durchbohren
stattdessen waren wir immer im
krisenmodus unterwegs und die jetzige
Regierung ist auch im krisenmodus
unterwegs
die große Krise war war die Pandemie
aber davor hat man natürlich auch eine
Finanzkrise und andere Krisen das ist so
ja weil sie sagten die Finanz genau es
war die Finanzkrise dann kam die
Energiewende dann kam die Euro-Krise
dann kam die flüchtlingskrise die
corona-krise um jetzt die ukraine-krise
und die gesamte Bundesregierung ist
jetzt fokussiert auf dieses eine Thema
und das darf in Zukunft nicht mehr so
sein aber das eigentlich Koalition ja
aber die Themen die Entschuldigung aber
die Themen hängen ja alle miteinander
zusammen erhöhte das ist ja gerade das
Problem ist ja eine wahnsinnig komplexe
Krise wir haben ja auch immer noch eine
Pandemie wir haben wir haben ein höheres
flüchtlingsaufkommen auch darüber wurde
heute gesprochen im Kanzleramt wer das
finanziert
wir haben die Ukraine Krise oder wie
eine Wirtschaftskrise dadurch
Energiekrise also das macht doch so
schwer ja das macht schwer aber man muss
dann auch fragen welche staatlichen
Ebene haben welche Aufgabe hintergrund
ist die Verfassungsordnung die
Schuldenbremse ist mehrfach erwähnt die
gibt eigentlich nur den Bund überhaupt
Spielräumen insofern ist es richtig dass
der Bund die große
Finanzierungsverantwortung übernimmt
aber ebenso richtig wäre es auch wenn
die Länder nicht gleich bei jeder Sache
die zusätzlich kommt immer in Berlin
vorstellig würden ich finde das ehrlich
gesagt auch ein bisschen
fast unerträglich weil die Länder haben
eine Verantwortung mit ihren Kommunen
gemeinsam für die Daseinsvorsorge und
dafür haben sie ein langfristigen
Auftrag und die müssen sich eigentlich
viel eher und insofern würde ich an dem
Punkt Lindemann sozusagen das ein
bisschen einordnen der Bund hat die
Krisenpolitik einen großen Ganzen zu
Menschen ist immer gesamtstaatliche
Krisen sind und der muss dafür auf
finanzpolitisch die Dinge Schultern
aber die Länder die haben die Aufgaben
sich dauerhaft um ihre Bürger und um die
Kommunen und die Lebensverhältnisse
können sie müssen nah bei den Menschen
das leisten sehen ich will mal ein
anderes über die reden jetzt über die
Themen die wir hier aber nehmen Sie mal
Pisa wir sind zu in 2011 über 2016 auf
das Jahr dass wir die letzten Pisa haben
permanent bei allen
Kompetenzen den Grundschülern und nach
unten gelaufen die ganze Bundesrepublik
Deutschlands heute auf dem Niveau von
Bremen 2011 und dann wissen wir wo
stehen Bremen war damals Platz 16 und
das ist ein Versagen in der in der
Verantwortung von Land und Kommunen
gesamthaft für dieses Thema das ist
keine konjunkturfrage das ist keine
Strukturkrise das ist dauerhaft zu
leisten bekommen nicht wirklich weiter
und jetzt kommen die Krise jetzt kommen
die sofort an bei jedem Thema Flucht was
welche Verantwortung haben wir denn in
den Länder wozu brauchen wir denn 16
Bundesländer wenn ihr nicht in der Lage
sind mal originär ein paar Aufgaben sich
heute sehr einig dass sie das das ist
genau Zahlen wollen die sich immer gegen
den Bund weil medias geregelt haben ja
letzten finanzausgleichsreform den
Finanzausgleich gibt es nicht mehr das
wird im Umsatzsteuer für die Fachleute
im Umsatz schon vorwegausgleich geregelt
es gibt nur noch die Front Länder gegen
den Bund es gibt überhaupt gar kein
Verständnis dass die Länder eine eigene
Verantwortung haben und deswegen muss
ich sagen wenn ich diese Konferenz auch
eigentlich nicht mehr erträglich der
Bund in jedem anderen Land wird die
Zentralregierung das machen was die
zentrale Verantwortung ist und wir haben
bei uns diese aber da müssen die Länder
sich auch mal anders einbringen das
glaube ich ist ein Nordrhein-Westfalen
Ministerpräsident hat heute gesagt es
gab keine Kompromissbereitschaft beim
Bund die hat er vermisst wir sind nicht
am Ziel das ist so wenig das ist nur ein
weiterer Fehler
würde ich auch langsam mal fragen
mit oder gegeneinander vorbei
einer einer Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen als alle sagen ja das
müssen erstmal warten müssen ja auch der
einzige der das gut fand heute die
Ergebnisse ja aber beim Wettbewerbs
Föderalismus also im Bereich Schule da
versagt der Föderalismus da gebe ich
Ihnen recht also es ist nicht so dass
ich sozusagen alle auf das beste
Beispiel einigen sondern jeder macht
seinen Stiefel und
am meisten leiden die Kinder darunter
ganz gebe ich Ihnen aber nicht recht
herzlich der natürlich haben die Länder
eigene und die Kommunen eigene Aufgaben
und die sonst sich kümmern das ist eben
das Prinzip des Föderalismus und wenn
man nach England oder Frankreich guckt
und dann lernt man den auch schätzen
also da ist es nicht so dass die
Zentralregierung in London über eine
Brücke in Hall entscheidet sondern bei
uns bei uns gibt es eben mehrere
Metropolen und es ist und nicht alle
gucken auf Berlin schade für Berlin aber
es gibt regionale Leuchttürme insofern
hat der Föderalismus durchaus viele gute
Seiten und klar die Länder und die
Kommunen müssen sich um die Leute vor
Ort kümmern müssen sich um ihre Bürger
kümmern und dann verstehe ich aber auch
dass sie natürlich das Geld dafür
brauchen ich sehe nicht sie haben es
besteht besser ausgestattet als der Bund
ja nein beim beim auf dem Papier aber
beim Punkt Regionalisierungsmittel also
nehmen wir das beispielverkehr also
jahrelang wurden Strecken stillgelegt
jahrelang wurden Strecken vernachlässigt
ja jahrelang hat sich die Deutsche Bank
aufs Kerngeschäft konzentriert und jetzt
sind die Länder die für den Nahverkehr
zuständig sind wieder an der Reihe das
auszubauen und dafür brauchen sie Geld
logischerweise es wurde ja jahrelang
kaputt gespart es gibt einen riesigen
Investitionsstau und nun ist es doch
klar dass man nicht sagen kann ja wir
schieben euch hier 1,5 Milliarden Euro
rüber und dann stehen die Leute an der
Bahnsteigkante da fährt aber kein Zug
weil da ist kein Geld dafür da du kannst
ja nicht sein
nach den Eindruck als Führer es geht
häufig zu wie auf dem Basar das sind
sehr fataler Eindruck da wird
Geschäftchen gemacht dann rede mal wo
Vermittlungsausschuss da wir das Recht
Geschäftchen gemacht hier keiner mehr
versteht und man hat den Eindruck dass
der Bund auch immer mehr mit mit
Projekten in eine Regelförderung
reingeht also Sprachförderung in Kitas
wenn irgendwas eine Kernaufgabe einer
Kita ist dann ist es Sprachförderung und
da setzt dann der Bund ein Projekt auf
damit die Länder Sprachförderung
bezahlen können das wird ihr wirklich
und haben wir ganz viele Beispiele nur
richtig ist der Bund ist nun mal der der
die Kompetenz hätte auch Mittel zu
besorgen er kann das über die
Kreditaufnahme Hüter als gesagt das
können Länder so nicht er könnte das
aber auch über eine andere Steuerpolitik
und solange wir eine Steuerpolitik haben
die insbesondere von den Lindner
Verantwortung wird wo bevor eine
Koalition überhaupt anfängt jegliche
Steuererhöhung zum Tabu erklärt wird und
dann kann passieren was will der kann
kriege ich ausbrechen da kann Energie
diese kommen und ein Finanzminister sagt
immer nein auf Himmels Willen keine
Steuer nee da was hier ist so kann man
natürlich dann hat man ein Problem und
dann kann ich die Länder auch gut
verstehen die sagen dann besorgt es doch
irgendwie anders wenn ihr euch weigert
Steuerzahlen was für bräuchten wäre nach
dieser Zeiten wenn da auch eine
finanzwende und da weigert sich Herr
Lindner und damit die ganze
Bundesregierung wäre das ein Ansatz auch
erhöhter dass man sagt also zum einen
muss man zielgerichte gerichteter und
genauer verteilen aber man muss
vielleicht auch mal von ein paar
Menschen etwas fordern die mehr haben
als andere also wir haben die höchste
Steuerquote in der Geschichte 24 Prozent
insofern ist es ja keine
unterausstattung mit Steuermitteln und
die Frage ist ja in was mache ich mit
welchen Quellen und deswegen ist es ja
richtig wenn das noch mal deutlich sagen
dass die 200 Milliarden in einer in
einem Kreditfonds ermöglicht werden um
diese Zusatzlast und diese Situation
auch zu beantworten dauerhaft muss
müssen Aufgaben aus den normalen Mitteln
die Länder wollten vor über zehn Jahren
bei der Verfassungsreform keinen
verschuldungsspielraum sie haben darauf
2012 in einer Situation wo wir jeden
Euro bräuchten in dieser Krise um
durchzukommen da habe ich kein Dampf
viele Menschen kein Verständnis mehr ist
Eingriff in die reale Einkommen
was wo ist denn bei ihnen so ein Punkt
wo man sagt also in so einer starken
Notlage dann könnten doch die die
wirklich mehr haben starke schultern
könnten auch ein bisschen mehr schultern
die könnten ein bisschen was abgeben
wie gesagt ich würde das zielgerichtet
machen und nicht die starken Schultern
wie Sie es nennen entlasten sondern
diejenigen die es brauchen ich würde
aber auch nicht belasten sie müssen
wissen wir haben in Deutschland ein
besonderes mittelstandsmodell über 80
Prozent der Unternehmen in Deutschland
sind ja de facto Personengesellschaften
die Zahlen Einkommensteuer und die
werden dann alle jetzt belastet sie
glauben gar nicht was bei mir los ist
wir haben Bäckereien wir haben die
Maschinenbau den Anlagenbau und viele
jeder ruft mich an jeder kommt auf mich
zu wenn ich jetzt sage wie entlasten
nicht zielgerichtet aber stattdessen
irgendwann noch die Steuern die würden
wir einfach nur den Vogel zeigen okay
also das ist tatsächlich schon sie haben
mit dem freiberufe angefangen und dann
plötzlich vom Bäcker und Maschinenbauern
und anderen gesprochen das sind keine
Freiberufler die würde man also mit
einer Erhöhung bei einer Einkommensteuer
nicht erreichen wie man erreichen würde
wären zum Beispiel DAX Vorstände die im
letzten Jahr ihre Einkommen um 26% auf 5
Millionen im Jahr hochschrauben und die
müssten dann abgeben und das finde ich
wären sehr gutes Signal ich würde gerne
mal fragen wie sie auf Freiberufler
kommen es gibt große Unternehmen die
Einkommensteuer zahlen das hat nichts
mit freiberuflernen zu tun und die
möchte ich einfach in der jetzigen
Situation nicht belasten die kommen auf
mich zu ja reden Sie doch mal mit einer
Metallverarbeitung ich war am Freitag
bei einer bei einer
Feuerverzinkung bei einer Firma die acht
Millionen Euro Umsatz macht die letztes
Jahr 200.000 Energiekosten gezahlt hat
dieses Jahr 1,2 Millionen und dann komme
ich zu denen und sage ja pustekuchen ihr
müsst jetzt mehr Steuern zahlen er
Schneider das das ist vielleicht eine
Meinung von Berlin Mitte aber die
Realität vor Ort wenn Sie mit den
Unternehmen reden im ländlichen Raum
dann ist das eine andere Realität alle
Modelle die wir bisher hatten sei es bei
der Höhe von Einkommen zu
spitzensteuersätzen die aber überhaupt
nicht mehr im Moment diskutiert wird
groß sondern Vermögenssteuer ist das
übergewinnsteuer diskutiert denn alle
oder auch bei Erbschaftssteuer haben in
ihrem Modellen die Komponente drin das
natürlich in dem Moment wo die
Qualitätsprobleme auftauchen wo die
Gewinnmargen nicht so sind wie man sich
das wünscht dass dann auch Steuern
gestundet werden haben alle Modelle drin
das heißt man würde keinen vor die Wand
fahren lassen wenn man das nur
intelligent genug anpackt ich würde ganz
gerne mal darauf schauen wir haben ja
wir sehen ja schon dass es mehr Proteste
gibt und viel sagen das kann im Winter
noch stärker werden es geht immer diese
die wir reden dann über die Spaltung des
Landes die Frage ob das wirklich so ist
aber Frau Lehmann was wäre jetzt ein was
wäre wichtig um dieses Land
zusammenzuhalten in dieser extremen
Krise und wie kriegt man also gerade
auch im Osten ist sehr viel Unmut auch
viele Unternehmen die vorher Geschäfte
mit Russland gemacht haben die natürlich
von den Sanktionen betroffen sind die
halt eben dabei ist einfach Probleme
haben ich glaube es ist erstmal wichtig
dieses Land zusammenzuhalten das hat die
Politik auch erkannt und viel wird
natürlich von der Ausgestaltung der
gaspreisbremse jetzt abhängen wie ist
die ausgestaltet ähm wie werden die
Menschen tatsächlich entlastet es ist ja
jetzt so ein Preis von 12 Cent im
Gespräch bei einem also bei einem bei
einem grundkontingent von 80 Prozent des
vorjahresverbrauchs das bedeutet dann
immer noch dass die Menschen doppelt so
hohe Gaspreise zahlen also und gerade
für die Menschen im Osten Deutschlands
da wird immer gesagt das sind alles
Putin verstehe aber so ist es nicht es
ist objektiv so die Leute haben
geringere Rücklagen die haben kaum
Vermögen gebildet es werden niedrigere
Löhne gezahlt die Rente ist nach 45
Jahren was nicht 200 Euro niedriger also
da wäre es eigentlich sinnvoll dass man
neben dieser gaspreisbremse weitere
Hilfen für Leute die es brauchen zur
Verfügung stellt und zwar schnell Geld
wäre ein Punkt zum Beispiel wohngeld ist
ein Punkt der ist aber also würde immer
gesagt das soll ganze soll zielgenau und
unbürokratisch sein das sind eigentlich
wieder streitende also Sachen die nicht
zusammenpassen denn wenn du was
zielgenau ist dann muss ein Antrag
gestellt geprüft werden das ist dann
demokratisch wenn was nicht zielgenau
ist dann ist es beziehungsweise wenn was
unbürokratisch ist das ist es in der
Regel auch nicht zielgenau dann sagt man
eben ja 300 Euro für jeden also insofern
wäre es schon wichtig dass dann noch
weitere Entlastung kommen und dann das
auch das Versprechen da ist jetzt nicht
Einmalzahlung vielleicht für die
nächsten Monat oder dann in dem
Vierteljahr wieder sondern dass man
tatsächlich prüft wie kann man die
Menschen in dieser schwierigen Situation
entlasten und so Beiträge also auch ich
meine das ist jetzt nicht genau das Ziel
noch aber wenn man sagt es kommt schnell
Nachfolger fürs neun Euro Ticket das
meinetwegen für Leute die wenig
verdienen 29 Euro kostet das wäre schon
eine Entlastung oder deutlich Entlastung
Wohngeld weil häufig gesagt wir soll
also überbürokratisch erstmal ist
richtig wenn man sich aber neulich im
Wohngeldantrag ausgedruckt da ich sag
mal lieber Mann dann mache ich lieber
eine Steuererklärung also die ist da ein
bisschen softer das heißt man kann es
abspecken man hat es in der Hand das
anderes was ich hier in Berlin erlebt
für corona-krise das kleine
selbstständige 5000 Euro überwiesen
bekommen haben die braucht nur rufen
nicht existiere und das habe ich auch im
Bekanntenkreis mitbekommen und dann
wurde am Ende musste es aber auch
wirklich zurückgezahlt werden wenn es
hieß ich brauche das nicht mehr das
haben die Menschen auch gemacht
ansonsten haben sie auch strafbar
gemacht also es ist das geht beim
Wohngeld genauso es geht auch gar nicht
also zum ersten Januar wenn die Leute
auftauchen und sagen ich habe
wahrscheinlich einen Anspruch brauchen
sie eine pauschale sieht das Gesetz auch
so vor und dann kann das abgearbeitet
werden ja trotzdem haben wir die Frage
wieder wie kriegt man das zusammen wie
kriegt man das auch im mit Blick auf den
Osten und auch auf die Auswirkungen des
Krieges wie kriegt man das alles
zusammen wir können uns keine besondere
Politik für die neuen Bundesländer mehr
machen das gibt es ja auch keinen
Sachgrund ich glaube man muss nur
erstmal ganz ehrlich allen sagen wir
werden ein Wohlstandsverlust erleben
dieser Krieg ist ein ein Auswirkungen so
dass es ein einkommensabfluss ans
Ausland gibt das ist schlicht und
ergreifend so das nicht von uns gewählt
und sein wir haben ein Ökonom sagen ein
terms of trade-effekt das heißt wir
müssen mehr ins Ausland Zahlen für das
was wir benötigen an energetischen
Grundlagen weil wir das nicht anders
machen können und das führt jetzt dazu
dass wir Übergangsphase die
symbolstandseinbusse haben und das
können wir nur kompensieren teilweise
und wir können das zielgenau
kompensieren da sind wir ja glaube ich
alle einig dass es auch zielgenau
gemacht werden muss bei Unternehmen
Lindemann hat sie auch noch mal erwähnt
würde ich immer die finanzamtslösung
wählen weil die immer am Ende
wiederkommen und nachrechnen wenn es
nicht nötig war zu Stunden wenn es nicht
nötig war Vorauszahlung zu erstatten
dann kommt das Finanzamt hat die Daten
beim privaten Haushalten finde ich in
der Tat die wohngeldlösung attraktiv
weil sie über den eigenen
transferbereichen unteren Steuerbereich
hineingeht weil man ohne hin vorhat und
das ist auch hier parteiübergreifend
durchaus ein Thema mit Blick auf das was
an transformationskosten also jetzt
nicht der Krieg sondern die
Klimaneutralität kommt mit dem Klima
Geld zu kombinieren und es setzt ja das
Wohngeld dort an wo die Kosten sozusagen
explodiert
die da sehr weit funktionieren kann wenn
man es einfacher organisiert und wenn
man sozusagen wirklich schnell macht
dass es dann auch hinterher wird immer
kontrolliert da können wir auch
draufsetzen wie viel Sorgen machen Sie
sich über Proteste auch gerade im Osten
einen Anwachsen der AFD
sehr sehr viele Sorgen ich war die Tage
länger da ich habe auch zwei drei Jahre
in Chemnitz gelebt während meine
Studiums und der Promotionen also ich
kenne die Situation sehr gut und es gibt
ein Problem im Moment in Deutschland
Herr Hüter sagt zu Recht wir müssen uns
auf Wohlstandsverluste
einstellen das heißt aber auch dass
vermutlich mehr Leute aus der
Mittelschicht immer mehr in die
staatliche
Abhängigkeit gezogen werden das muss man
einfach wissen es Wohngeld sind
staatliche Mittel wenn jetzt noch
zusätzlich das Bürgergeld kommt
Sanktionen abgeschaffen werden die
Heizkosten übernommen werden dann ist
irgendwann der Punkt erreicht wo
wirklich derjenige der arbeitet der
morgens 6 Uhr auf dem Wecker
die Bilder die mag man nicht mehr hören
er schneidet
zum Beispiel gar keine Zeit mehr wir
sind schon am Ende der Sendung
wir hatten wir hatten den OST im Osten
eine Arbeitslosigkeit 1997 und 2005 von
fast 20 Prozent und die sind da
rausgekommen die Menschen durch durch
Leistung Arbeit hat sich gelohnt wenn
dieser Zusammenhang in Deutschland nicht
mehr da ist dann kriegen wir ein Problem
dann erodiert etwas insoweit darf
wir haben letztes schon über das
Bürgergeld diskutiert und werden das
sicherlich auch noch öfter machen also
vielen Dank Herr Hüter Herr Linnemann
Frau Lehmann und Herr Schneider für
diese Diskussion vielen dank ihnen fürs
zuschauen morgen sind wir wieder für Sie
da und dann schauen wir noch mal auf die
Ukraine was dort gerade passiert
Vormarsch der Ukraine wie geschwächt ist
Putin wirklich also wir freuen uns auf
Sie morgen bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]